really horrible story coming out of los
angeles homeless deaths in los angeles
have increased over the past five years
this is people who die because of
exposure just die on the street and
they've increased not by a little bit
but by 200
in just five years nearly 2 000 homeless
people died in l.a county last year
according to a report by the new york
times 100 hundreds of those who did so
did so in plain sight of passersby
people just walking on by them
287 of these people died on the sidewalk
another 72 were found on the pavement
24 of them died in alleys
this is based on a report from the l.a
county coroner
is that humane
the libs tell us that if if we do not
let bums and derelicts and mentally ill
people and addicts live and squalor on
the street that we're cruel we're
anti-homeless we're inhumane you think
this is humane
i don't think this is humane at all
i think it's a horrible disordered thing
that we allow people to live on the
street
i remember back during occupy wall
street so this was probably 10 years ago
now rudy giuliani speaking of this as a
new yorker as someone who's the best
mayor of new york probably in that
city's history came out and he said this
is a simple question don't let people
live on the street
living on the street is a disordered act
that harms the individual and harm
society
why why are the libs in la doing this
they're doing this because
it's nice
they think it's the nice thing to do i
guess it is the nice thing to do it you
don't bother the homeless people you let
the drug addicts do what they want to do
at least what their appetites want to do
and you just hands off not my problem
i'm gonna look away but it's not loving
it's not loving at all you're letting
these people
live in squalor experience great pain be
completely discarded by society and then
die
and you're seeing their their
death numbers go through the roof
it would be much more loving to force
these people into homeless shelters
force these people into rehabilitation
centers force the criminals among these
people into prisons that would be much
more loving it's tough love sure but
it's a much more loving thing and that
that is the conservative answer
and what the libs want to convince us
that when we get back to reality and get
back to basics and enforce the
fundamental
lowest bar basic
functions of a society that were cruel
and inhumane not at all it is completely
completely
the opposite
i'm so glad you liked that clip if you
want more clips head on over and
subscribe ring that bell you'll get many
more clips go subscribe to the michael
knowles show too we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]